This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。“绝对真人。”2%。这是当电梯和自动扶梯同时存在时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将深入剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关乎心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字就是两个字母“TO”。当一群女性发现她们约会过的对象居然都是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他将罪有应得。我们总说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回顾往昔》（The Look Back at it）播客。对1979年来说，那是对我而言意义重大的一刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格利什。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如谈论80年代的马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾往昔》。嘿，大家好，你们好！欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯为您带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方都算不上安全，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《艰难一课》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大批网络侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. You specifically. No one else. Back for another episode. Maybe it's your first episode. I'm not sure, but welcome. Welcome as we break down the psychology of our 20s. I think, We all know the feeling of having an amazing conversation with a friend, with someone you've just met,
后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十几岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里。特指你。没有别人。再次收听新的一期节目。也许这是你的第一期节目。我不确定，但欢迎。欢迎和我们一起剖析二十几岁的心理学。我想，我们都知道那种感觉：和一个朋友、一个刚认识的人、
with your partner. You know, the minutes just float by. You feel so aligned and in sync. You're excited. You're like buzzing with this energy. Like someone is kind of like put a mirror in front of us and is reflecting back all of these deep beliefs and funny anecdotes and stories, making us feel seeing and heard, but also being like very entertaining, maybe deep. it is a certain kind of high and one that I want all of us to have more often.
或者和你的伴侣进行一次极好的对话。你知道的，时间就这样悄悄溜走。你们感到如此契合、同频。你感到兴奋。你整个人因为这种能量而兴奋不已。就像有人在我们的面前放了一面镜子，映照出我们所有的深层信念、有趣的轶事和故事，让我们感到被看见、被倾听，同时又非常有趣，或许还有些深邃。这是一种特定程度的亢奋，也是我希望我们所有人能更频繁体验到的。
Conversations really unlock some of the best things about us, our capacity to share knowledge and to learn, to be vulnerable, to show deep emotion, to connect, to be persuasive or likable. But whilst talking to others may seem like it should just be like one of the easiest things in the world, that is not always the case. whether you are naturally shy, you're dealing with social anxiety, you've kind of just lost a bit of your spark and simply need a reminder of what connects us to others. Sometimes we do need to be reminded and have a bit of a refresher on what makes a good conversation. I also think listening and communicating is something that we can all get better at. It is such a valuable skill to be able to talk to anyone you meet and not just talk but actually connect, especially in our 20s, there are just so many new people to me and to get to know and the connections that we make now
对话确实能激发我们身上一些最美好的特质：我们分享知识与学习的能力、敞开心扉的能力、展现深厚情感的能力、连接他人的能力、展现说服力或讨人喜欢的能力。然而，尽管与他人交谈看起来应该是世界上最简单的事情之一，但实际情况并非总是如此。无论你天生害羞、正在应对社交焦虑，还是仅仅失去了一点灵感，需要有人提醒你究竟是什么将我们与他人连接在一起。有时我们的确需要得到提醒，并对什么才是一场好的对话进行温故知新。我也认为，倾听和沟通是我们所有人都可以不断提升的能力。能够与你遇到的任何人交谈，而且不仅是交谈，更是真正产生连接，这是一项非常宝贵的技能，尤其是在我们的二十几岁，有那么多新面孔需要我去认识和了解，我们现在建立的连接
really influence and change our entire lives. And this is the skill to have of the more. It's so applicable to every area of your life to be a good conversationalist to your dating life, making friends, job interviews, networking. So let's talk about it today. How can we have better conversations? What makes some people so easy to talk to? Why do we click more with them than others and what are their secrets? How can we learn from them? On top of that, what does the psychology and the science really say about good conversations? Is the secret listening? Is it body language? Is it specific questions or pauses?
真的会影响并改变我们的一生。而这正是需要掌握的技能，它是如此普适，适用于你生活的方方面面——无论是在你的约会生活中、结交朋友、求职面试还是人际交往中。所以我们今天来聊聊这个。我们如何才能进行更好的对话？是什么让某些人那么容易交谈？为什么我们与他们的默契比其他人更多？他们的秘诀是什么？我们如何向他们学习？除此之外，关于好的对话，心理学和科学究竟是怎么说的？秘诀是倾听吗？是肢体语言吗？是特定的提问还是停顿？
There are entire careers that have been established on investigating this very question. So I have five tips for you today to have the best connections and conversations you have ever had a bit of a formula for when it's tricky and essentially how we can control, you know, our interactions and the things that we can control about our interactions and our conversations to make them deep and meaningful and amazing. So if you know me, you know I love a big old chat and I am so pumped for this episode and I honestly learnt so much that I can apply to my own lives. So without further ado, let's get into it.
已经有整整一个职业群体在致力于研究这个具体的问题。所以今天我有五个建议要送给大家，帮你建立你经历过的最好的连接和对话；这算是一个公式，当对话变得棘手时可以使用，本质上讲，是如何控制——你知道的——我们的互动，以及我们可以控制的互动和对话中的种种因素，让它们变得深刻、有意义且精彩。所以如果你了解我，你就知道我喜欢长篇大论，我为这期节目感到无比兴奋，老实说，我也学到了很多可以应用到自己生活中的东西。所以，废话不多说，我们切入正题吧。
Good conversations don't always come naturally. That is a fact. It's so interesting because we are never taught how to have good conversations. We are just kind of expected to pick it up along the way and get accustomed to the kind of rules of engagement. Make eye contact. Find something we have in common. Don't stray too far from what's relevant.
好的对话并不总是自然而然发生的。这是一个事实。这很有意思，因为从来没有人教过我们如何进行好的对话。我们只是被期望在摸索中逐渐学会，并习惯这种交往规则。进行眼神交流。找到共同点。不要偏离主题太远。
Small talk first. Sometimes though, something just doesn't click even when we have done it all right. I have even found that with some of my closest and longest friends. There will just be days where it's like trying to fit. a triangle through a circle. That can sometimes cause a spiral. You know, this whole line of questioning around whether we're actually compatible or even that close or even get along. Because being able to hold an interesting conversation is such a mark of inherent chemistry between two people. What we don't always account for are the mental distractions that we are
先进行闲聊。不过有时候，即使我们把这一切都做对了，某个东西就是无法产生共鸣。我甚至在一些最亲密、交往最久的朋友身上也发现过这一点。总会有那么几天，感觉就像是在强行把一个三角形塞进圆形里。这有时会导致情绪的螺旋上升。你知道的，这一整串质问都围绕着我们是否真的契合、甚至是否真的那么亲密、又或者是否真的合得来。因为能够维持一段有趣的对话，正是两个人之间存在内在默契的标志。而我们有时没有考虑到的是我们
each facing. The to-do lists, spiraling off in the back of our minds, the over-stimulation or mental exhaustion that sometimes just makes us poor communicators. So for our first tip, I wanted one that it doesn't really matter what you have going on in the mental background, you can still apply it. Because conversation isn't just about you, it's about the other person. Instead of trying so hard to keep the spark alive by just feeling the silences and just saying more. Tip number one, ask more questions than you answer.
各自面临的精神干扰。待办事项清单、在脑海深处盘旋的想法、过度刺激或精神疲惫，这些有时只会让我们成为糟糕的沟通者。所以在我们的第一个建议中，我想要一个无论你的大脑背景里正在发生什么都可以依然适用的方法。因为对话不只是关于你，它也关乎对方。与其费尽心思地去通过填补空白和说更多的话来维持火花，不如采用建议一：多问问题，少回答。
people love talking about themselves, but they love talking about themselves even more when they have something to talk about, when they feel inspired, and when they feel listened to. The easiest way to trigger all three of these things is to simply ask them a really good question. The best communicators and conversationalists are people who understand the two-to-one ratio. For every question that they ask you, ask two of your own, whether that's a follow-up question to a previous thing they've said, or to kind of introduce a brand new topic. I know that sounds quite mathematical and very clinical, but a conversation is very much like a scenic walk, or like a very long drive. The best kinds are the ones with twists and turns,
人们喜欢谈论自己，但当他们有话可说、感到受到启发、并且感到被倾听时，他们会更喜欢谈论自己。触发这三点最简单的方法，就是简单地向他们提出一个真正好的问题。最优秀的沟通者和对话者是那些理解“二比一”法则的人。你向对方提出的每一个问题，自己就要提出两个问题，无论是对他们之前说过的话进行追问，还是借此引入一个全新的话题。我知道这听起来很数学化、很刻板，但对话非常像是一场风景优美的散步，或者是一次漫长的车程。最好的那些车程往往充满了曲折，
with new scenery, with little stops along the way, with new environments, and they're also the best when somebody is driving, right? When somebody is guiding you through a conversation, through a new situation, questions are a way to do that. And being intentional and deliberate about how much you are talking versus listening, that is really, really valuable. This is actually called a doorknob for psychologist researching conversations. Basically, you know, a very important part of a conversation is providing somebody with, you know, something that they can grab onto that opens up a new space.
有新的风景，有沿途的小停靠站，有崭新的环境，而且当有人在开车时感觉也是最好的，对吧？当有人指引你穿越对话、穿过一个新情境时，提问就是做到这一点的途径。并且有意识、有目的地权衡你说话与倾听的比例，这是非常非常有价值的。在研究对话的心理学家眼中，这实际上被称为“门把手”。基本上，你知道的，对话中非常重要的一部分就是为对方提供某种他们可以抓住的东西，从而开启一个新的空间。
So a good question is the doorknob. And it is essentially, you've planted it there, but it's a way for somebody else to feel like they are really, you know, accepted and guiding this conversation and that it's taking them to a new level. The power of questions might seem quite simple, but at its core, the reason this is so effective comes down to attention. A really great article published by Psychology Today put it really well. attention has its own magic. We as humans crave recognition from others, and there is a lot of experimental evidence that says being ostracized or ignored by others
所以一个好的问题就是门把手。它本质上是你播种在那里的，但它是一种方式，让另一个人觉得他们确实——你知道的——被接纳，并且在引导这场对话，这把他们带到了一个新的高度。提问的力量似乎很简单，但其核心在于，之所以如此有效，归根结底是因为“关注”。《今日心理学》发表的一篇非常棒的文章很好地阐述了这一点：关注本身具有某种魔力。我们作为人类，渴望得到他人的认可，并且有大量实验证据表明，被他人排挤或忽视
creates a pain that is every bit as real and intense as physical injury. So to counteract that, we should show people that we want to be interested in us and who we are interested in, that we are paying attention to them. According to social attention holding potential theory, which you should really Google. It's very interesting. This is a theory developed by the British psychologist Paul Gilbert. We often tend to compete with each other to have people pay attention to us.
所带来的痛苦，在各方面都与身体受伤一样真实且剧烈。因此，为了抵消这一点，我们应该向人们展示，我们希望他们对我们感兴趣，以及我们对谁感兴趣，我们在关注他们。根据社会关注保持潜力理论（你真的应该去谷歌一下，非常有趣），这是由英国心理学家保罗·吉尔伯特提出的一种理论。我们往往倾向于互相竞争，以吸引人们对我们的注意。
When other people take notice, we feel good. We enjoy all kinds of positive feelings, confidence, belonging, acceptance. You want to create those feelings in another person. Knowing that you are being heard by the other person often makes you like them more. That is the principle of reciprocity. And in the study conducted at Harvard in 2017, what this team explored was that when you feel like someone is reciprocating your energy in a conversation, when you apply, the two to one ratio, for every question they ask you, you ask them too. It also actually makes them like you more, which is definitely a perk. So in this study, they had a series of couples participate in a speed dating event,
当其他人注意到我们时，我们会感觉良好。我们会享受各种积极的感受：自信、归属感、接纳感。你想在另一个人身上创造这种感觉。知道自己被对方倾听，往往会让你更喜欢对方。这就是互惠原则。在2017年哈佛大学进行的一项研究中，这个团队探讨的是：当你觉得有人在对话中对你的能量给予回应时，当你应用“二比一”法则——他们问你一个问题，你问他们两个——这实际上也会让他们更喜欢你，这绝对是一个额外的好处。所以在研究中，他们让一系列情侣参加了一场快速约会活动，
people that didn't know each other, and they found a really positive correlation between somebody asking more questions and the likelihood of them securing a second date. So it's very easy to see why questions are so charming. They basically demonstrate your, you know, your liking of somebody else, which they are more likely to return, and also your wish to kind of build a mutual connection and understanding of their experiences. But here is the thing. Questions are great and interrogation is not.
彼此并不认识的人，他们发现某人提出更多的问题与他们获得第二次约会的机会之间存在非常正相关的关系。所以很容易看出为什么提问如此迷人。它们基本上表明了你——你知道的——对另一个人的好感，而对方更有可能对此做出回报，同时也表明你希望建立相互连接以及对他们经历的理解。但问题是这样的：提问很棒，但审讯可不是。
That is the rule of thumb there. So on that note, there are some questions that are superior to others. Tip two is to learn what they are and use them more. This is especially important when we're meeting new people, trying to make new friends, new connections. Obviously, there are some basic kinds of questions that we should learn to avoid, like yes or no questions. Or questions that essentially back people into a corner and make them do all the little. legwork. But even deeper than that, researchers have actually investigated what questions are best to ask somebody new. And this list is a bit strange, but it includes questions like,
这就是那条经验法则。因此，基于这一点，有些问题确实比其他问题更好。建议二就是了解这些问题并更多地使用它们。当我们结识新朋友、试图建立新友谊、新连接时，这一点尤为重要。显然，我们应该学会避免某些基本类型的问题，比如只能回答“是”或“否”的问题。或者那些基本上把人逼入绝境、让他们不得不承担所有繁重琐事的问题。但比这更深层的是，研究人员实际上已经研究过，向新认识的人提出什么问题才是最好的。这个列表有点奇怪，但它包括以下问题：
what are you feeling grateful for at the moment? What's a big dream for the future that you have? If you could change anything about how you were raised, what would it be? And even stranger ones, like, if you could wake up tomorrow and have gained one ability, what would you like it to be? Do you have a secret hunch about how you will die? Obviously, you are not going to settle up to somebody at a party that you've never met and ask them, oh yeah, how do you think you're going to die? Car accident or cancer, like that's crazy. But these questions are part of what is known as the fast friends protocol or procedure,
你目前对什么心怀感激？你对未来有什么宏大的梦想？如果你能改变自己成长方式中的任何一点，那会是什么？甚至还有更奇怪的问题，比如：如果你明天醒来就能获得一种超能力，你希望它是什么？关于你将如何死去，你有什么秘密的直觉吗？显然，你不会在一个从未谋面的派对上走到某人面前去问他们：“哦，对啦，你觉得自己是怎么死的？车祸还是癌症？”这太疯狂了。但这些问题是被称为“快速交友协议或程序”的一部分，
which is essentially a series of questions you can find online that move from fairly basic to really personal. And the hypothesis is, any two strangers could ask each other these questions and form a close friendship. You may be familiar with some of these questions if you have heard about the 36 questions to fall in love, because they are essentially the same thing. And the creator of these questions, Dr. Aran and his wife, tested these questions in a lab to determine which were most effective and why. So they got two people who had never met in a room and they had them answer a series of questions. One series of questions imitated small talk.
本质上这是一系列你可以在网上找到的问题，从相当基础的问题逐渐深入到非常个人的问题。其假设是：任何两个陌生人都可以互相问这些问题，并建立亲密的友谊。如果你听说过“让人坠入爱河的36个问题”，你可能会对其中一些问题感到熟悉，因为它们本质上是同一回事。这些问题的创造者阿伦博士和他的妻子在实验室里测试了这些问题，以确定哪些最有效以及原因何在。因此，他们把两个从未见过面的人关在一个房间里，让他们回答一系列问题。其中一系列问题模仿了闲聊。
you know, where did you go to high school? What did you do on the weekend? Do you have any pets? And the other series of questions are the 36 questions that we now know and love that made that final list. They then followed up with the pairs in each conditions. Seven weeks later, they went to them and they said, so did you end up wanting to be friends with that person? Did you end up forming a relationship, forming your friendship? What was amazing was that, you know, this study was in the 90s.
你知道的，你在哪儿上高中？你周末做什么？你养宠物吗？而另一系列问题就是我们现在熟知并喜爱、最终进入该名单的36个问题。然后，他们在七周后对处于每种条件下的配对人员进行了回访。他们找到这些人并问：“所以，你最后想和那个人做朋友吗？你们最终建立起关系、建立起友谊了吗？”令人惊叹的是——你知道的——这项研究是在90年代进行的，
this was pre-social media. These people had to really work pretty hard to find their partner. And over 50% of those who were in that full disclosure group who had the 36 questions had formed such a connection and a bond during that period that they had eventually actually made contact or become friends. 50% of them. And these people had never met before. And that was how this list was made.
那是在社交媒体出现之前。这些人必须真正付出相当大的努力才能找到他们的伴侣。在那些处于全面坦白组、被问及36个问题的人中，超过50%的人在这段期间建立起了如此深厚的联系和纽带，以至于他们最终确实取得了联系或成为了朋友。占了50%。而这些人之前从未谋面。这就是这个列表的诞生过程。
The reason why the researchers found these people, questions so effective is because they all contained three important elements. They were surprising, they were personal and they weren't something that we immediately had the answer to. So compare these two questions to see this for yourself. How was your day versus tell me about something excited that happened to you? Which of these are you immediately going to be more excited to answer? Also note that we are basically asking the same thing. You could give the same answer to both of those questions, but one of them is more inviting. So be more creative with your questions, be curious, search for what you actually want to know more about, or even better,
研究人员发现这些问题如此有效的原因在于，它们都包含三个重要元素：它们出人意料、非常私人化、并且不是我们能立刻得出答案的东西。所以，对比以下这两个问题，你就能亲身明白这一点：“你今天过得怎么样？”与“跟我讲讲发生在你身上的某件令人兴奋的事。”面对这两个问题，你哪一个会立刻觉得更有兴致去回答？还要注意，我们基本上问的是同一件事。你可以对这两个问题给出相同的答案，但其中一个更有吸引力。因此，让你的问题更具创造力，保持好奇心，去寻找你真正想了解更多的东西，或者更好的是，
what you can notice the other person really wants to discuss. Often they'll give us clues by returning to that point or that topic again and again, show that other person that you care, don't ask more questions, ask better questions. All right, let's move on to tip three. Number three, actually probably my favorite tip, stop story topping and bright siding. So I picked up this tip from an amazing TED Talk by Celeste Headley that is very aptly titled Ten Ways to Have a Better Conversation. It's a must listen if you want even more tips after this. But she said something really profound in this TED talk. It's only natural to want to share more about ourselves because that is where we think we find a spark or something meaningful and mutual.
你可以注意到对方真正想要讨论的是什么。通常，他们会通过一遍又一遍地回到那个观点或话题来给我们提供线索。向另一个人表明你在乎，不要问更多的问题，要问更好的问题。好了，让我们进入建议三。第三点，可能可以说是最喜欢的建议，停止“抢风头”（story topping）和“盲目乐观”（bright siding）。所以我从萨斯特·海德利（Celeste Headley）的一场精彩TED演讲中汲取了这条建议，该演讲的标题非常贴切：“如何进行更好对话的十种方法”。如果你在这之后还想要更多建议，这绝对是必听之选。但她在这次TED演讲中说了一些非常深刻的话。想要更多地分享关于我们自己的事情是很自然的，因为那是我们认为能找到火花或某种有意义且共同之处的地方。
But the worst way we can do that is by thinking about a conversation is competition. Hearing someone's story about their breakup or their promotion or their unfortunate commute and coming back with our own story that has five times the amount of plot twists and surprise turns. It is never the same. Your situation is always going to be different and it doesn't make them feel heard. It's not about you. Don't take that moment. Conversations are not a promotional opportunity.
但我们这样做的最糟糕方式，就是把对话当成一场竞争。听到别人讲述他们分手、升职或通勤不顺的故事，然后用我们自己的故事来回应，而我们的故事却有着五倍之多的情节反转和令人惊讶的转折。这从来都不是一回事。你的处境永远是不同的，这并不会让他们觉得被倾听。这并不是关于你。不要抢占那个高光时刻。对话不是促销的机会。
Again, sometimes it is our way of relating to others. I think people with ADHD, for example, this can be especially difficult because oversharing and relating something to somebody else's experiences is sometimes a technique or a different way of expressing empathy, right? Especially for people with ADHD or autism. It's their way of saying, I see your experiences so much so, and I'm so appreciative of them, that I took the time to relate it to my own experiences. and now we have something in common.
再次强调，有时这是我们与他人产生共鸣的方式。例如，我认为对于患有多动症（ADHD）的人来说，这尤其困难，因为过度分享并将某事与他人的经历联系起来，有时是一种表达同理心的技巧或不同的方式，对吧？特别是对于患有ADHD或自闭症的人来说。这是他们表达“我非常理解你的经历，并且我对此深表感激，以至于我花时间把它与我自己的经历联系起来，
And, you know, that's a nice thing. But I think realizing that maybe that's not how they interpret that is important. And just provide a caveat. Before you jump into your own story, say something like, oh, you know, I know it's not the same. I've kind of been there, but in a different way. Oh, wow, that's a really interesting story. It reminds me of this.
现在我们有了共同点”的一种方式。你知道的，这是一件好事。但我认为意识到也许别人并不是这样解读这一点的，这一点很重要。只需加一个前提条件。在你插话讲自己的故事之前，说一些类似这样的话：“哦，你知道的，我知道这不一样。我也曾有过类似经历，但方式不太一样。”“哦，哇，这是一个非常有趣的故事。这让我想起了这个。”
It's not as bad as what happened to you, of course. You know, just really showing them that you're not trying to want up them. You're trying to relate to them. And kind of finishing your story with a question means that, you know, it's not about you trying to one-up them. It's about you trying to extend and continue the conversation rather than cut it off. This doesn't mean that you don't contribute and build on a conversation or try and find some mutual ground, just that you recognize how you can do that in ways that still let the other person feel seen and heard. The same goes for bright siding.
“当然，这没有你遭遇的那么糟糕。”你知道的，只是真诚地向他们表明，你不是在试图胜过他们。你是在试图与他们产生共鸣。并且用一个问题来结束你的故事，意味着——你知道的——这并不是关于你试图在气势上压倒他们。这是关于你试图延伸和延续对话，而不是将其掐断。这并不意味着你不去贡献和推进对话，或者不去寻找一些共同点，只是意味着你意识到如何用依然能让对方感到被看见和被倾听的方式来做到这一点。盲目乐观也是如此。
So this is a term that was created by an amazing. amazing author called Barbara Enreach, who talks about how when she was diagnosed with cancer, everybody kind of approached her with what she called in her words, reckless optimism, right? She had cancer. She was in hospital and they would be, they would ask about her day and she would say it was terrible. It sucked. And they'd be like, well, you know, on the bright side, X, Y, Z. Well, think about it this way. Again, it's a natural inclination for someone to tell you how awful their day was and for you to want to encourage them or lift their mood. Sometimes it is simply an emotional reflex, a form of empathy.
所以这是一个由一位出色的作家芭芭拉·埃伦赖奇（Barbara Enreach）创造的词，她谈到当她被诊断出患有癌症时，每个人都用她自己的话说的那种“鲁莽的乐观”来接近她，对吧？她得了癌症。她躺在医院里，他们会问起她今天过得怎么样，她会说糟透了。烂极了。而他们会说：“嗯，你知道的，从光明的一面来看，X、Y、Z。”“嗯，换个角度想。”再次强调，当有人告诉你他们今天过得有多糟糕时，你想要鼓励他们或提升他们的情绪，这是一种自然的倾向。有时这只是一种情感反射，一种同理心的形式。
But you know what? It's not always helpful. And it really shuts things off immediately. It's just, you know, just by our best intentions, even if things are awkward, it can come off as you wanting to move on and ignore their obvious attempt to talk about something that is vulnerable or deeper. There is nothing wrong with just saying, that is really awful, how are you feeling now?
但你知道吗？这并不总是奏效。而且它确实会立刻把谈话关死。这只是——你知道的——出于我们最好的意图，即使事情很尴尬，它也可能会表现为你想继续前进，并忽略了他们试图谈论脆弱或更深层事情的明显尝试。说出这样的话并没有错：“这真的很糟糕，你现在感觉怎么样？”
Or, well, that really sucks what happened after that and letting them get back to the positive side of things if they want to. Letting people feel shit sometimes and not needing to be their therapist or their hype man is also a really incredibly powerful way to feel closer because emotional acknowledgement and respect is such a significant form of platonic and even romantic intimacy.
或者，“发生在那之后的事真的很糟糕，”然后让他们在愿意的时候回到事情积极的一面。有时允许人们感到沮丧，而不需要成为他们的心理治疗师或啦啦队长，也是一种极其强大的拉近距离的方式，因为情感上的承认和尊重是柏拉图式甚至是浪漫亲密关系的一种重要形式。
Like, yes, we feel safe enough around each other that you can let me pick behind the curtain, that you invited me in. You don't always have to be on. You don't always have to be happy and I'm still going to be there for that. And we can still have a conversation that isn't necessarily cheery and surface level. Okay. So a quick refresh of what we've spoken about so far. Number one, ask more questions for every one question ask two.
就像，是的，我们在彼此身边感到足够安全，以至于你可以让我窥探幕后，你邀请我走进来。你并不总是需要表现得完美。你并不总是需要快乐，而我依然会为你守候。我们仍然可以进行一场不一定非得欢快和流于表面的对话。好的。那么我们来快速回顾一下目前所谈的内容。第一，多问问题，问一个问题就要问两个。
But number two, not all questions are made equal. so focus on those that are surprising, personal and different. And number three, no bright siding or story topping if you can help it. I have two more tips for you. Of course, we have to talk about technology somewhere in this episode and the impact that our phones have on our conversations, but also how your confidence in part determines conversational success. The energy that you put out is what you receive back.
但第二，并非所有问题都是生而平等的。因此，要把重点放在那些令人惊讶、充满个性且与众不同的问题上。第三，如果可以避免的话，不要盲目乐观，也不要抢别人的风头。我还有两个建议要送给大家。当然，我们在这期节目中必须在某个地方谈到科技，以及手机对我们对话的影响，但同时，你自身的自信也在一定程度上决定了对话的成功。你散发出的能量就是你所接收到的能量。
So we are going to talk about that. And so much more after this short break. You know that feeling when you're telling the story that you've kind of been waiting to tell all day, you literally can't keep it in and you're midway through you're talking to like a group of three or four people and like half of them suddenly turn away and start talking to somebody else or go on their phones? It immediately makes you feel like you should be quiet and no one wants to listen to you. No one likes to feel that way.
所以我们将在短暂的休息后讨论这个以及更多内容。你知道那种感觉吗：当你正在讲述那个你一整天都憋着想讲的故事，简直按捺不住，讲到一半时——你正在跟三四个人说话——突然他们中的一半人扭过头去开始跟别人说话，或者玩起了手机？这立刻会让你觉得自己应该闭嘴，根本没人想听你说话。没有人喜欢那种感觉。
No one likes to have somebody else's lack of engagement shoved in their face. And our biggest culprit in these situations is our phones. So number four, our rule for better conversations, when you get the urge to pick up your phone, ignore it for just another five minutes, and spend that time being really focused on what your friend, your boyfriend, your girlfriend, your new acquaintance is saying. It doesn't mean that you can't grab your phone in five minutes,
没有人喜欢把别人缺乏参与感的样子直接甩在脸面上。而在这些情况下，我们最大的罪魁祸首就是手机。因此，第四点，我们进行更好对话的规则是：当你产生拿起手机的冲动时，请再忽略它五分钟，并把这段时间花在真正专注于你的朋友、男朋友、女朋友或新认识的人正在说的话上。这并不意味着如果在五分钟内有人给你发了电子邮件，
minutes if somebody has emailed you, but ignore that initial urge. And often what you will find is that you quickly become re-engaged in the conversation pretty quickly when you put technology off limits for just a brief moment. You know, let's be honest, there is a difference between in-person and online conversing. One of them is definitely more fulfilling than the other one. Anyone who has ever, for example, used a dating app or been long distance with their partner will confirm that for you, in-person conversations, Trump. And they have a really really, extraordinary power to excite our brains, especially when they are face-to-face, because our, you know, our brain is so socially wired. And so our neurons are very sensitive to face-to-face engagement.
你不能抓起手机，但请忽略那种最初的冲动。你往往会发现，当你把科技产品搁置短短的一会儿时，你很快就会重新投入到对话中。你知道的，坦白说，线下交流和线上交流是有区别的。其中一种显然比另一种更有满足感。任何曾经使用过约会软件或与伴侣进行异地恋的人都可以为你证实这一点，面对面的对话更胜一筹。而且它们拥有真正非凡的力量来激发我们的大脑，尤其是当它们是面对面的时候，因为我们的——你知道的——大脑在社交上是高度连线的。所以我们的神经元对面对面的互动非常敏感。
When somebody is standing in front of us, making eye contact, showing positive non-verbal cues, that they are interested, that they are listening, this rapidly activates reward systems in our brains. But our phones can break that trance and they pull us away with their kind of like, a lure of instant gratification and many of their addictive properties. But, you know, not only is it not a good habit to get into, to not always fulfill the urge to grab your phone, it also just immediately cuts off the kind of connection that you're building with somebody. It immediately brick walls and stone walls them. That little dopamine hit that you're getting from your phone is, I just think, not worth it. And it sounds so simple. It probably doesn't.
当某人站在我们面前，进行眼神交流，展现出他们感兴趣、他们在倾听的积极非语言信号时，这会迅速激活我们大脑中的奖励系统。但我们的手机可以打破这种出神状态，它们用即时满足的诱惑和许多成瘾特性把我们拉开。但是，你知道的，这不仅不是一个好习惯——无法总是克制住抓手机的冲动，它还会立即切断你与某人正在建立的连接。它会立刻筑起砖墙和石墙。你从手机那里获得的微小多巴胺刺激，我只是觉得，根本不值得。这听起来很简单。可能甚至
doesn't even need mentioning, but your phone can wait when you're having a good conversation. You know, that TikTok notification, that like new Instagram follow, whatever it is. It's still going to be there in two, three, five minutes when this person has been able to finish their train of thought, when there is a natural pause, when they finished responding to your question. And you might even find that once you fight that urge, remember, it's only five minutes, there's actually a whole new, deeper plane of conversation that opens up in front of you. You know, the other thing that I want to say on this, why I'm like such a big believer in
都不需要提及，但当你进行一场愉快的对话时，你的手机可以等一等。你知道的，那个TikTok通知、那个新的Instagram关注，无论它是什么。当这个人能够把他们的思路说完、当有一个自然的停顿、当他们回答完你的问题时，它在两分钟、三分钟、五分钟后仍然会在那里。你甚至可能会发现，一旦你战胜了那种冲动——记住，只有五分钟——其实有一个全新的、更深层次的对话层面正在你面前徐徐展开。你知道的，关于这一点我还想说的是，为什么我如此坚信
like putting your phone away when you're really wanting to connect with somebody, is that it really does teach us the distinction between the long-term pleasure and enjoyment of a good conversation versus the instant gratification of our screens. I think fighting the impulse to grab our phones also teaches us a valuable difference between the kind of value and satisfaction we get from those two different forms of communication. You know, yeah, a deeply engaging chat can sometimes feel a little bit arduous or tricky in the moment if you're maybe running out of things to say or you feel stuck. But choosing to push through that and find common ground or just sit with each other often leaves
当你真正想要与人连接时要把手机收起来，是因为它确实教会了我们长期的对话乐趣和享受，与屏幕带来的即时满足感之间的区别。我认为，与抓手机的冲动做抗争，也教会了我们这两种不同形式的沟通所带来的价值和满意度之间的宝贵差异。你知道的，是的，一场深度投入的聊天有时在当下可能会让人觉得有点费力或棘手，如果你可能快没话说或者觉得卡壳了。但选择坚持下去、找到共同点或只是静静地陪伴彼此，通常会
us with a greater sense of comfort in the long term compared to the dopamine, the tiny spike, or hit of serotonin that our brains are going to give us. It's like the impact of eating healthy versus like the yumminess of a chocolate bar that's going to make us crash later on. So if you are truly committed to having better conversations, put your phone in your bag, put it in a different room. Sometimes me and my boyfriend do this thing called phone-free evenings because, you know, we've noticed that it's normally at crucial moments that we feel the need to pull out our phones. It's when we've hit a lull and we should be pushing forward. it's when the other person is expressing something about their day and just needs to rant. And the other one sees it as an opportunity to kind of scroll Instagram or whatever.
让我们在长期获得一种更大的舒适感，相比之下，我们的大脑由多巴胺带来的微小尖峰或血清素刺激则显得逊色。这就像吃健康食品与巧克力棒的美味之间的区别，后者稍后会让我们感到精力崩溃。因此，如果你真的致力于进行更好的对话，把你的手机放进包里，或者放到另一个房间去。有时我和我男友会做一件叫做“无手机之夜”的事情，因为——你知道的——我们注意到通常是在关键时刻，我们才觉得有必要掏出手机。那是在我们陷入冷场、而我们本该继续推进的时候。那是当另一个人在表达他们关于某天遭遇的感受、只是需要发泄的时候。而另一个人却把它视为滚动浏览Instagram或做其他事情的机会。
You know, no, silence. Them having a long, you know, rant or vent is not an invitation for you to do your own thing. It is an invitation to really listen. One final tip. Tip five, here we go. This one is uniquely about us and only us. Let go of worrying about how you are coming across. A lot of us spend a lot of time evaluating ourselves or thinking about what this other person is thinking whilst we're conversing.
你知道的，不要这样。沉默。他们进行长时间的抱怨或倾诉，并不是邀请你去做你自己的事。这是一个真正倾听的邀请。最后一条建议。第五个建议，来咯。这条完全关于我们，而且只关于我们。放下对“自己给别人留下什么印象”的担忧。我们很多人在交谈时，都会花大量时间去评估自己，或者去琢磨对方在想什么。
And in general, this really interferes with connecting with others because the focus is on something completely unrelated to the topic at hand. It also creates some of those awkward moments where you're so busy picking yourself apart, scrutinizing what you're wearing or your facial expression, whether you're engaged or not, you actually end up missing. what they're saying and then they turn to ask you a question and you just go blank. I've had that happen before. There's nothing worse. Honestly, we're probably just concerned with how we're coming off, that we're getting two in our own heads that actually their opinion might change of us because we are so kind of detached. We kind of our eyes glaze over. Here's an interesting psychological phenomenon for you that may set you at ease and it's called the liking gap. The liking gap basically says
总的来说，这确实会干扰与他人的连接，因为注意力的焦点完全放在了与手头话题无关的事情上。它还会制造出一些尴尬的时刻：你太忙于剖析自己、审视自己穿的衣服或面部表情、纠结自己是否专注，以至于你实际上错过了他们所说的话，然后他们转过头来问你一个问题，而你的脑子却一片空白。我以前也经历过这种情况。没有什么比这更糟糕的了。老实说，我们可能只是担心自己给人的印象，以至于我们在自己的脑子里想得太多，而对方对我们的看法反而可能会改变，因为我们表现得如此冷漠。我们的眼神开始呆滞。这里有一个有趣的心理学现象可以让你放松下来，它被称为“喜爱差距”（the liking gap）。喜爱差距基本上是说，
that people like us a lot more than we think they do. When we first meet someone, we tend to assume the worst. But in this research paper published in 2018 out of Cornell University, when researchers put two people together to chat and then afterwards got them to rate how they felt about themselves in that conversation, how they thought the other person thought about them and how they thought about the other person, they tended to rate us higher and themselves lower. But we were doing the same thing, right?
人们其实比我们想象的要更喜欢我们。当我们第一次遇到某人时，我们往往会往最坏的方面想。但在2018年康奈尔大学发表的一篇研究论文中，研究人员让两个人坐在一起聊天，然后在事后让他们评价自己在这场对话中的感觉、他们认为对方是如何看待他们的、以及他们是如何看待对方的，结果是他们往往对我们的评价更高，而对自己评价更低。但我们在做同样的事情，对吧？
The other person was doing the exact same thing. Nearly everyone was thinking, yeah, I'm coming off super weird in this conversation, but they're doing great. So the irony there is definitely not lost on us. The evidence really showed you're doing better than you think. You're actually pretty darn good at making a great first impression. Research aside, when you find yourself getting into that self-analysis paralysis,
另一个人也在做完全相同的事情。几乎每个人都在想：“是的，我在这场对话中表现得超级奇怪，但他们做得很好。”所以其中的讽刺意味对我们来说绝对是显而易见的。证据确实表明：你比你想象的要表现得更好。你在给人留下第一印象方面其实相当不错。抛开研究不谈，当你发现自己陷入那种自我分析的麻痹状态时，
I always say it can feel like you're at the back of your brain when you want to be right at the front, right? Like you want to be really present. You want to put all that energy into that other person. And sometimes we can't help it. If you, you know, really want to impress this person or you're battling a moment of social anxiety, it can just come over us. But remember, confidence is the best costume.
我总是说，这感觉就像你躲在大脑的后方，而你其实希望身处最前方，对吧？就像你希望真正保持专注。你希望把所有的能量都投入到另一个人身上。有时我们身不由己。如果你——你知道的——真的很想给这个人留下深刻印象，或者你正在与社交焦虑时刻作斗争，这种情绪就会压倒我们。但请记住，自信是最好的伪装。
Genuinely, if you needed the reminder, no one can read your mind. No one can see your anxious thoughts. if you just project utmost confidence in yourself and put all the intention and focus back on them. I've talked about this tip so many times that if you are a regular, you won't be new to this. But the thing that has helped me more than anything else, in these times in particular when I'm feeling super anxious about what somebody else is thinking, is picturing this big golden orb in my chest. And this orb, this golden bubble, makes me magnetic. and it makes me alluring and confident to anyone that it touches.
说真的，如果你需要提醒的话，没有人能读懂你的心思。没有人能看到你焦虑的想法。如果你只是向自己投射出极致的自信，把所有的注意力和焦点重新放在他们身上。我已经谈过这个建议很多次了，如果你是老听友，这对你来说并不新鲜。但对我帮助最大的——尤其是在这些我对我对别人的想法感到超级焦虑的时刻——是想象我胸口有一个巨大的金色光球。而这个光球，这个金色的气泡，让我充满磁性。
And with each breath, the orb just gets bigger and bigger before it begins to surround and encircle everyone around me, including the person I'm talking to. And honestly, it works every time. People shift and respond to how you are feeling about yourself. And if you have a mindset and an attitude of self-assurance, an interest and calm, that is what they will see. they will see what you decide to show them.
它让我对接触到的任何人都充满吸引力和自信。每一次呼吸，光球都会变得越来越大，直到它开始包围和环绕我周围的每个人，包括和我说话的人。老实说，每次都管用。人们会根据你对自己感觉如何来做出转变和回应。如果你拥有自信、兴趣和冷静的心态与态度，那就是他们会看到的。他们会看到你决定向他们展示的东西。
So take a deep breath for a second. Activate your orb and just remember, thinking about others' perceptions of you in a conversation is counterproductive. If you want other people to like you, to respect you, to value you, really listening to what they have to say and building a connection through attention is so much more powerful than, you know, anything else that you can do, than any witty story, than any analysis.
所以花一秒钟深呼吸。激活你的光球，并记住：在对话中思考别人对你的看法是适得其反的。如果你想让其他人喜欢你、尊重你、重视你，真正倾听他们要说的话并通过关注建立连接，要比——你知道的——你能做的任何其他事情、任何机智的故事、任何对你所有微小行为和举动的分析，都要强大得多。
of all your small behaviors and actions. Some final lightning round tips for you guys to have better conversations. Don't be afraid of silence. Good conversations also need a break just like us. Mirror body language. This is scientifically proven as a way of showing empathy because mimicking how somebody is sitting or physically reacting to us, signals their mirror neurons and makes them feel more connected to us.
最后为大家提供一些闪电般的快问快答小建议，帮助你们进行更好的对话。不要害怕沉默。就像我们一样，好的对话也需要休息。模仿肢体语言。这在科学上已被证明是一种表达同理心的方式，因为模仿某人的坐姿或对我们的身体反应，会触发他们的镜像神经元，让他们觉得与我们联系更紧密。
Relax your face. pull up your chin, open your eyes. This is also a way to show attention and intrigue through facial expressions and body language. And don't go all in too soon. Don't try and create artificial intimacy because you think that that might make you closer, quicker. Sometimes it backfires so people feel overwhelmed. So approach from a slow burn perspective. You don't have to play all your cards now. You do have time. You'll get to know them more later on. Just take it slow. And finally, if the conversation is dying out, let it, it's okay, conversations are like dating. Sometimes they're not all going to be the one.
放松面部。抬起下巴，睁开眼睛。这也是通过面部表情和肢体语言来表达关注和兴趣的一种方式。不要过早地全情投入。不要试图制造虚假的亲密感，因为你觉得这样可以更快地拉近距离。有时这会适得其反，让人感到不知所措。所以，要以一种循序渐进的方式接近。你现在不必亮出所有底牌。你确实有时间。以后你会更了解他们。慢慢来就好。最后，如果对话正在渐渐冷场，那就随它去吧，没关系的，对话就像约会。有时它们并不都是对的人。
So it's okay to step back, excuse yourself to the bathroom and start again with somebody else. I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope that you got something out of it, whether it was cool scientific fact or a tip or just a boosting confidence. I really enjoyed speaking about this. I love talking to people. Hopefully you can apply these tips in your own life. And if there is somebody that you think needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them.
所以退一步也无妨，借口去洗手间，然后和另一个人重新开始。我真心希望你喜欢这一期节目。我希望你从中有所收获，无论是酷炫的科学事实、一个小建议，还是仅仅是自信心的提升。我很享受谈论这个话题。我喜欢和人交流。希望你能将这些建议应用到你自己的生活中。如果你觉得有人需要听听这一期节目，请随时分享给他们。
Or leave a five-star review, wherever you are listening right now. It only takes a few seconds, and it really, really helps the show to grow, and I just really appreciate it. If you have an episode suggestion, the easiest way to let us know is to just DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And if you want to see behind the scenes, you can follow me at Gemma Spag. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk soon.
或者在任何你现在收听的地方留下五星好评。这只需要几秒钟，而且真的对节目的成长有很大很大的帮助，我对此非常感激。如果你有节目建议，最简单的联系方式就是在 Instagram 上私信我：That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看看幕后花絮，可以关注我的账号：Gemma Spag。直到下次，注意安全。保持善良，对自己温和一点，我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变。成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
就在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。收听《Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
相信我，宝贝。就在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild... It was a wild...
在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84年是一个疯狂的……这是一个疯狂的……
Wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be.
疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。
be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men. who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini.
不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在 2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测报告你造假了两次，对吗？我造假了一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名男子。经历过同样事情的人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App 上收听《Love Trapped》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts，或在任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。有保证的人类。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。